[Music]
do you guys
know who tracy chapman is yeah country
singer well not country
i don't know if i would classify his
country is she is she
i know i know i've never heard one song
from her and it does sound like country
i think a tracy atkins does she hold a
guitar she does hold the kind of
she does she does hold a guitar she
could be country so the genre is fo
folk blues rock pop soul oh cool
yeah there's not in there good so uh
she's famous for
like the the song that i knew her for
was the um
give me one reason the give me one
reason
i can't i can't i can't do it elaborate
try it
help i try try again sing the other
words give me one reason
to shine my shoes
she's a 90s artist i know which song
you're talking about but i forgot the
lyrics after that
because you didn't continue it i don't
know the lyrics make the noise
something like that yes see he knows he
knows anyway so that's
um i don't care if he knows i don't know
if you know you know let's just say
without singing
to him and then he will sing it
so anyway you know who's on cobra kai
[ __ ] asthmat
okay keep going okay random movie
references that's the game
okay anyway so the reason why we're
talking about her is because she's
suing nicki minaj oh [ __ ] over like a
copyright claim uh-oh copyright child
she's trying to be like youtube now well
no i mean in the music industry music
industry now she just ripped off her
song
she's ripped off her song or use her
beat um so she ended up
using yeah so nicki minaj pretty much
did a cover
of one of tracy chapman's songs called
baby can i hold you which was released
in 1998 or 1988
and so nicki minaj she ended up
doing her own song called sorry which
borrowed heavily
from tracy chapman's song and i'll play
it in a second
um we're gonna get demonetized well i
play it for us are you seeing it it
won't get demonetized
no or it might get demonetized depending
[Laughter]
yo i think that was like the pinnacle of
her oh but i'm not playing that game
i'm just stupid we're not playing
that game nobody ever asked who's it
honey by the way
i'm listening can i ask one thing it
better be about this story
remember the seventh heaven
she married yeah but remember after
she bent over she opened up that
refrigerator in that one movie
i think it was like marvel movie or
whatever i'm not pronouncing chuckling
or something everything have to be about
sex with you pour your belt
i never saw it the jedi wearing a belt
today that's the adam sandler movie
you guys left out come on because i
don't have my belt
what would you do with the belt i told
you i was listening
i don't know what movie you're
referencing right now
[Laughter]
we're supposed to guess what the movie
is i get it i get it
i don't watch mexican film i keep
telling tarantino
nacho libre anyway
back to the story so um like i said
nicki minaj used
chapman's song like or borrowed heavily
and so
apparently minaj's team kept repeatedly
asking tracy chapman for permission like
can we use your song but
tracy chapman is on a do not sample list
and she
repeatedly denied the
all that and so she was just like no
like you you can't have my song
you can't have it she said that she
would respond in a timely and respectful
manner
constantly like so nicki minaj's team
knew for sure like
you can't use tracy chapman at all then
they're just like [ __ ] it anyways
we're going to sample that song and now
that we're in big troubles well should
be like alibaba so here's the thing
nicki minaj never officially released
this song
she did make the song she never
officially released the song oh and
a dj in new york uh funk master flex
oh i forgot him yeah so he did
cars too he did play the song on how did
he get it
quick click clan so he did play the song
and ron right
but yeah so then so nicki minaj tweeted
out back in 2018
she said i'm torn y'all help tracy
chapman can you please hit me
omg for the love of hashtag queen but
then she deleted that tweet
but i don't know why but um
well actually i do know why because
nicki minaj is pretty much claiming like
well i didn't know that we didn't have
permission to even make this song
yeah he does start it it sparks an
interesting debate um and they're pretty
much asking questions like wait so
can artists be held liable for copyright
infringement for
works in progress because like are you
saying that now
artists need permission to even
experiment in the studio to begin with
because it hasn't been published right
is that is that the argument it hasn't
been published so
questions yeah how can i copy something
that hasn't been published
uh yeah cause like you could just take
any random song and just remix it but if
you don't release it it's just like
i thought like an artist doing their own
rendition of a
copyrighted piece of artwork like i
don't know like
disney or whatever i don't know simpsons
and then but
they just make it they just make it
and then they're not um but they're not
profiting off of it like isn't that okay
like to try out your artistic so is it
copyrighted or not this song
regardless if it's released or not the
tracy chapman song uh tracy chapman yes
that was released
tracy chapman's song is released nicki
minaj's song is not but it was played on
radio which
into like wait nikki did you secretly
leak it like are you behind
this song getting out there in the
public because if you are then you're
liable
to a lot of fees i see yeah that's what
the story is here so you're asking me
for what we should do
no i'm not asking what would you do i'm
telling you the story
what do we think is the rest of the
story don't say anything my
unprofessional legal advice i think you
should be able to experiment as much as
you want in the studio that's gonna be
chinese
and also a lot of djs a lot of djs and
beat makers they do that right they like
they're just inspired they pull music
and especially like
like if you're trying to make like
quote-unquote soul beats and you're like
sampling and all that and then after
they feel something they feel like they
have something they're really proud
of then they'll actually reach out to
the original publisher and go can i have
the rights to this
yeah so then that's when so that's why
like nikki's group is arguing that
her creation of her song sorry even
without a license from chapman
is protected under fair use which is an
exception to copyright law that lets
creators borrow copyrighted material
under certain
conditions but if she was the one that
actually
released this out there and she didn't
get the license
like that just causes problems so what
ended up happening in september a judge
sided with nicki minaj about the whole
question of fair use
he was probably a fan too pretty good at
this stuff biased he was a fan but if
nikki makes money i think tracy should
make some money off that song
so what ended up happening here though
is that the judge even though she was
siding with
nicki minaj she did let this go to trial
so
like this this case was about to go to
trial but then
what ended up happening is uh nicki
minaj just settled
like they made an offer to tracy chapman
for 450 000
inclusive of all costs and attorney fees
incurred two dates
on december 17th and then chapman's team
accepted it on december
30th so do we get did they get the
license though
because we went through something
similar um so
we had a video bank i mean we had a
sound bank that we bought
and uh we used that music
for some of our skits and things like
that another company actually
bought that same royalty-free sound bank
right and we couldn't produce the
receipts for it because this was over 10
years ago
and they came after us and said hey
you're using
our copy written music for your youtube
videos
and we're like oh [ __ ] this sucks man
and then we found out that there's a lot
of companies out there that were doing
that to
uh online like content
check people down now yeah so they would
buy
uh licenses they would buy all of these
different
sound banks that unlicense them or like
take it back
and take it back or they would go after
people who
couldn't produce the receipts for it and
that's [ __ ] up
yes so that's basically what happened to
us that's happened to us too on our
channel like yeah with our own friends
yeah so that's almost like paying double
for it right because you paid
for like who would have thought like
when you first start out as a youtuber
right like you're not me
even making that much money and then
there's all these different things that
you can get
uh copyright free royalty-free music
from
right and then you're just like i want a
soundtrack to my skit so you pay like
100 bucks or something and you don't
think to like
hold this because one day you're going
to become famous or whatever
you just kind of buy it and use it it's
going to change your algorithm and like
just hunt every single yeah yeah and
then and you can
you can risk your whole channel from
being taken down for using
uh copyright writing material so it kind
of sucks that it happened but it's also
like a
lesson learned like oh [ __ ] you know you
gotta keep records of
everything did you settle and yeah we
had to settle because we couldn't
produce the receipts we just had no
[ __ ] clue where the
uh yeah like we know we bought it or
whatever we just couldn't find where it
was tiff you just said it happens to you
in your channel with your own friends
yeah so we've we have friends that
created
our music we have friends that have
created music and then
after years go by then they'll end up
selling their music or their rights to
music to these bigger companies and then
so now it's like being copywritten and
then they're coming after our channel
and saying like
hey now you're using same situation same
situation but we're like well we have
permission from the artist but that's
not enough the artist doesn't own the
song anymore no that [ __ ] happened to me
by myself to yourself we didn't even if
you could show the date that you posted
it and that's when you got permission
and all that kind of well we had to
clear it that way
he was handling it doesn't matter like
you need the license the license or the
permit is literally what counts and
don't
move faster the bots don't have there's
no time for the bots to
receive like what your rebuttal is it
just goes down video goes down yeah we
have a [ __ ] ton of our videos on our
vlog channel that is demonetized
i got uh hit with one for someone
stealing my own content
so i have all those videos i posted on
instagram people took that and like
was in like random like fail
compilations and then i posted that
that just clip on my uh youtube in like
a regular video and then that portion of
it got or like the whole video got
demonetized because
the money was going to them and i was
like this is my video but they just took
him that's me failing
in that video right there they literally
steal people's content make a
compilation of it
and if you try using that type of
content like or fail videos
it all goes to them not to the right you
know why it's because they beat you to
licensing your content so they stole
your content they licensed it and then
they can go ahead
and catch you for your own car it's not
even licensing they just
literally upload it to youtube but then
with the youtube algorithm if they have
they're making claims because they
uploaded it first yeah because they do
the enable id match or whatever
so oh so you posted it somewhere else
that wasn't youtube
yeah that's your content that that's how
it got out there but then this other
random person posted it to youtube so
they got youtube's
permission first yeah damn
that's crazy man with facebook because i
never posted anything on facebook but
then people started posting my old
videos on facebook
and like cleaning up with them and then
obviously i don't there's companies
that um because one of my friends does
it where he uh pays the company it's not
even that much
but then they go and backtrack all that
and get all their money back
oh nice yeah so you can probably make
hello money doing that interesting oh
i should probably look well bitcoin
wasn't going so well perhaps i would
look into that
[Music]
you